So trusted path means that you really
talking to the trusted computing base or
the operating system, okay.
So path that connects
you typing the keys and
where these keystrokes
are being captured.
That path is really connecting you and
the trusted computing base and
there's no one else in between.
If that is the case,
you have a trusted path.
How do you make sure you
have a trusted path?
We're going to talk about
a couple different ways.
This trusted path really has to be
provided by the operating system,
maybe some combination of
hardware as you look at
combination of the operating system and
the hardware as we're going to see.
So for example, if you login to Windows,
you have to press this key sequence,
Ctrl+Alt+Del.
The idea is that you
press this key sequence.
This sequence cannot be
trapped by any other program.
Great, this is going to take
you to the operating system.
So the display and the keyboard has
to be connected to the CPU on which
the operating system is running in
a way that there is no one in between.
Display is not under
control of somebody else.
And somebody else is not able
to capture the key strokes and
perhaps even alter them and
things like that.
So generally these are sort
of physically connected,
isn't it and they're in close proximity,
they're right next to your CPU,
both the display and the keyboard.
So we assume there's no
one else in between.
But if you're paranoid we can do sort of
couple of different things to make sure
that really we're not talking to
somebody else but the operating system.
People had to propose a bunch
of different ideas to make sure
that when you're authenticating
yourself you have a trusted path.
They said there's a special part of
the display that only the operating
system can write.
So for example you could indicate on
the display when you're talking to
the operating system and when you're
not talking to the operating system.
Or actually have a light
on the keyboard.
Okay, that will light up when you're
talking to the operating system and
it will be off when you're not.
So this way the user would
know that when it's providing,
I don't know, his or her password,
it is actually going over a trusted
path to the operating system.
The other entity, or
the entity at the other end actually,
is the trusted computing base.
So one challenge with these kind of
things is, do users pay attention to
something you display, or a light on
the keyboard or something like that.
If it's a red, flashing light maybe
they do, or something like that.
But the idea here is I think
the concept of a trusted computing path
is something we want to understand.